[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON ANDREAS: Welcome
to Talks at Google.
I'm Jason Andreas.
Most of you know me.
Some folks in from Ann Arbor.
We have a live stream going
out to the other Google office
as well.
So hello, everyone.
Welcome.
Thanks for coming.
I'm here with the incredibly
talented singer/songwriter
Shakey Graves.
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
JASON ANDREAS: Let's give
him a big Google welcome.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello.
[LAUGHS] Ooh, easy crowd.
Hi, how are you doing?
Hi, I'm Alejandro.
I'm Shakey Graves.
It's my morning.
I'm sure it's your actual
genuine afternoon right now.
So we'll try and meet in
the middle here, cheers.
All right.
I'm going to play some songs
for you guys on this guitar
that I wrote.
And I'm going to sing them too.
This first song is called
"Cops and Robbers."
It's off a record that I just
put out earlier this month,
and I'm going to play you
the relaxing ballad version
because it's my morning
and it's your afternoon.
That's going to be the
throughline of this.
[MUSIC - SHAKEY GRAVES, "COPS
AND ROBBERS"]
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
You guys have a
mighty fine office.
It's very strange to
be in an office for me.
It's kind of thrilling.
It's exciting.
I'm like, aw, offices have
slides and video games.
People are like, mm, no.
I'm sure it's kind of a trap.
I saw that video game section
up there and was like,
no one's there, because
they're at work.
That's good.
They're like,
yeah, come up here.
Come up here.
[MIMICS RADIO] Billy's upstairs
playing video games right now.
All right.
Here's a song about a
fictional character that--
now we started to refer to
all the fictional characters
in my music that
aren't specifically me,
which I don't write
a lot about me,
but now we call this
person Garth Nazarth.
That's the name
of the person that
is the central
protagonist in this song.
So this is a song about Garth
being really down on himself
and not working at a
cool office like this
and just be like, who am I?
[MUSIC - SHAKEY GRAVES, "DINING
ALONE"]
Poor Garth.
[LAUGHS] Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON ANDREAS: A huge
thank you once again.
That was fantastic.
Another round of applause,
please, for Alejandro.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Thank you.
JASON ANDREAS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I was telling, in
between, the quick set
change-- he was spot
on with the video game
reference, wasn't he?
No one ever plays video games.
Like, people who come visit,
they play video games.
But it's collecting
dust up there.
So--
SHAKEY GRAVES: I'm on to you.
JASON ANDREAS: --it's
a good recruiting tool.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
JASON ANDREAS: Cool.
Well, thank you so much.
You've been super busy.
We know you just came in
from Montreal last night,
trekked all the way
over to Detroit.
You've got the Royal Oak
Music Theater this evening.
You just released your
new album, which you just
rang two songs off for us.
So thank you again.
This just released
on, what, May 5,
I believe, so just a
couple of weeks ago.
And now you've got this
massive tour lined up.
All the way through November,
you're going over to Europe
and hitting a lot of
different countries.
You're playing, I think, Bottle
Rock, Sasquatch, Red Rocks,
the Ryman, the legendary
Ryman, Google Detroit.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Whoo!
I'm there!
I made it!
JASON ANDREAS: The
most iconic venue.
Yes.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Google Detroit!
Google Motor City!
JASON ANDREAS: You'll be at the
Ryman, like, this is nothing.
I've been to Google Detroit,
so everything is much worse.
That's a lot.
You're talking about
being in an office.
How do you find
the energy to push
through a schedule like that
and perform every single night,
come in and hang out
with us on your time off?
Where does all that
energy come from?
SHAKEY GRAVES: Oh my god.
I wouldn't say I have that
much energy all the time.
But the show and the music
that I've tried to make
allows me to have a
boring night if I want to.
I would hope that
kind of in general,
if I was in a full-on jump
up and down punk band and had
to do this, I have
no idea what--
it would have to be
like total sobriety
or like just like rahh!
Just the opposite side of
the spectrum or something.
JASON ANDREAS: I hear you.
SHAKEY GRAVES: I have no idea.
But luckily, you know,
there's a storytelling aspect
to the music I write.
I mean, performing is
thrilling in the first place.
So even if you're
not feeling like it,
being forced into a room
full of people sometimes
just throws a snake in
your shoes pretty quickly.
A little colloquialism.
You know, an old snake in your
shoes-- you guys have that?
No.
JASON ANDREAS: No, we do.
We use that up here
in Michigan too.
SHAKEY GRAVES: You also drop
snakes in people's shoes?
JASON ANDREAS: That's a
universal thing for sure,
the old snake in the shoe trick.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Right.
[LAUGHS]
JASON ANDREAS: I'm sure you play
off the crowd's energy as well
too, depending on what you come
out and play and how you start.
Because your music has
changed from this album
back to some of the first
albums that you put out.
So I guess you
could probably play
a little bit with the
crowd as well, based
on the type of energy you bring
and start with and end with
and things like that.
Do you think about that when
you put together a set list?
SHAKEY GRAVES: I do, yeah.
This tour kind of more
than any of them--
because I mean, each one
of these series of shows
that we've done--
I've been on the road since--
it feels like
continuously since 2012.
And that's not like an
accurate description of it.
But every bit of it is kind
of building a new piece
and realizing what you suffer
from from the last time
that I tried to, you know,
play six shows a week for three
weeks in a row.
And there's like, you can get
ahead of it with your brain
and try and be like,
OK, don't do this.
Do do this.
But it's kind of a
day-to-day basis.
And so for this
show specifically,
because of the new
record and new sounds
and technological
advances in guitar stuff,
it's a lot of new things
being introduced to a sound
that maybe some people perceive
as being more rootsy or organic
or, you know, like using
luggage as instruments.
JASON ANDREAS: Right.
SHAKEY GRAVES: But
so for this, I've
been reading a book by David
Byrne called "How Music Works"
that he put out in 2000 and--
JASON ANDREAS:
It's a great book.
SHAKEY GRAVES: It's
a great book, yeah.
And again, "Stop Making
Sense," the movie,
was always a big inspiration
for stage show, even years ago.
And I didn't really
reflect that.
But when I was introducing new
band members, because people
didn't even know I was
playing with a band,
I would kind of do
them one at a time.
And we used to do this
thing with my guitar player
where we'd plant
him in the audience
and pretend that he was--
I'd be like, does
anyone know this song?
He'd be like, me, me, me!
JASON ANDREAS: I knew it!
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah, we'd try
and like crowd surf him up,
and then, you know, he would
know how all the pedals worked.
And it was supposed to be a gag,
but you know, every night there
was somebody that was like,
wow, that kid was really good.
JASON ANDREAS: Incredible.
SHAKEY GRAVES: And
you know, and then
some people just could
immediately tell,
like, there's no way he knows
how all these pedals work
on this board.
And I've always tried
to play with kind
of showing the strings.
And specifically
with this record
is kind of more dream-oriented
and a little more psychedelic.
So the way that we have
our stage show was all--
like a week before we
went on tour, I was like,
guys we're going
to change the way
this stage looks and
tried to work on stuff
like hiding amplifiers so
you're not paying attention
to what gear we're
playing out of and using
manipulatable, practical
lights on stage
instead of depending
entirely on the house.
So we can control the
rise and fall of the mood
and sort of where things focus.
And I've been trying to
utilize like flashlights
and really basic
things that focus you
where you need to be paying
attention before it turns
into a massive show.
And so all of that has been
wonderful and way better
for my brain to focus
on than every day trying
to worry about, like,
how do I entertain?
Like, oh no!
Who am I tonight?
And it's like, nope.
Now I have to make sure
that the flashlights work
and that this stupid
reel-to-reel tape
machine that I have that plays
Martin Denny is on and simple,
like regular problems.
JASON ANDREAS: We face some
of those challenges here too.
Before you came out, we were
talking about our lighting
system as well back there.
And if there was a way for
me to use like a clapper
to change a color.
So life, if I asked like
a somber question, maybe
it would turn blue, if it was
a more upbeat question, green.
So we face the same challenges.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Can't you guys
like wire that into the heart
monitors that go throughout
the office or something?
And if everyone gets
real awkward, like ooh,
it will be like
[WHIRRING SOUND]..
JASON ANDREAS:
Artificial intelligence--
I just think I want blue
lights, and then they turn blue.
SHAKEY GRAVES: There we go.
JASON ANDREAS: That's coming up.
We're beta testing
that right now.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Good.
JASON ANDREAS: So
we'll get that out.
If it works, we'll get it
into your show routine.
It'll be great.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Let's do that.
That would be great.
JASON ANDREAS: Let's
talk about the new album,
because you talked about
it just a minute ago.
So it does have a new vibe for
all of the Shakey Graves fans
out there.
You know, his first four albums
were a little bit more rootsy,
Americana, folky a little bit.
And this definitely has--
I wrote down in my notes,
"a dreamlike sound to it."
Then I put, "Is that the
right way to describe it?"
I was going to ask you.
But you said it, so
hopefully that's right.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS:
It's a great album.
Where did the sound come from?
Where did this
progression come from?
Of course, all artists change
and progress and fine tune.
So why after four
albums did this
become kind of the inspirational
sound for the album?
SHAKEY GRAVES: I
mean, I would say
that this sound, the way
that this record sounds,
if I could have in
2010 made something
that sounded like this,
I probably would have.
And it's always been a
pleasure to kind of discover
what I sound like, so to speak.
One of the pleasures
of my life is
having to fight
with my own brain
about what I sound
like to myself,
because I'm like, I sound great.
And people are like, yeah, but
not for the reasons you think.
Like, you're not
killing this part,
but we like watching
you wiggle around.
Like, ah, that's
not what I wanted.
But for instance, you know,
this came out of necessity,
not like I'm going
to be some guy that
plays an abstract instrument.
It was like really
trying to figure out
how I could get a guitar
and a drum into my car
that I didn't have at the
time, so into someone's car
who would drive me
somewhere without too
much of a footprint, you know.
And I was like, I
can probably stuff
an amp inside of this thing.
And it was trying to make
consistent sound wherever
I went.
Because I had recorded a
record like this sort of,
the first one that I put out,
which sounds more rootsy,
but it also had a lot of voices
layered on it and me playing
multiple things.
And I couldn't do it live with
an acoustic guitar in front
of people.
So I learned a new way, and
then that became a new sound.
And then people were into me
doing this more than recording.
It's like weapons and armor.
You build one thing.
You know, for instance,
the way that I
played the songs earlier off
of this is not how they sound.
JASON ANDREAS: Not at all, yeah.
SHAKEY GRAVES: But
that's the pleasure
of finding what songs sound like
or how you even perform them.
JASON ANDREAS: Has
the process changed?
Your first album, which came
out five, six years ago,
seven years ago?
SHAKEY GRAVES: 2011, yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah,
seven years ago.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Seven years ago.
JASON ANDREAS: Good at math.
I didn't even use a
calculator for that.
That, and correct
me if I'm wrong,
but you recorded
that in your house.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Mhm.
JASON ANDREAS: Now, this
was recorded using--
if I read the story
correctly, you
kind of did this homage
tour around the country
to draw inspiration.
You stopped up in Woodstock,
New York and Levon Helms's bar.
And The Band is my
favorite band of all time.
You were in Austin, of course.
You were all over.
You stopped in Colorado
and different spots.
How did that play
in, from starting
in your house recording all
of the tracks, to this album?
Did it change or
did it not change?
SHAKEY GRAVES: I mean, the
secret is that I lied to you.
I didn't go anywhere
to do this album.
I did it all in my house.
JASON ANDREAS:
It's a great story.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah.
Exactly.
No, we did do those trips.
But the majority of this
was still made in my house
and finished in the house
and stuff like that.
But since I have
other band members,
and instead of
playing it all myself,
I really wanted this
to be a more cohesive,
collaborative effort.
And so instead of flying--
because my bass player lives in
New York and my guitar player
lives in LA.
And so instead of
flying them to Austin,
I realized quickly that
it's a lot more fun
and it's easier to take
something seriously
if you make a limited
event out of it.
Because if we're in Austin, it's
like, eh, we've got work to do.
And also at the same time, we
have tons of friends there.
And there's always like--
it's Margarita Monday
every day for some reason.
And it's just too easy
to not work at home.
And it works fine sometimes,
but to really try and make
sure we actually
finish something,
it was much more interesting
to go to Colorado
and rent a little house
and all live in it
and then wire that up.
So even when we went on
these recording excursions,
it wasn't usually to studios.
We still made the studio out
of the space we were in, just
like my house.
JASON ANDREAS: Got you.
So more inspiration
taken from some
of those places and then the
recording was done, kind of--
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah,
and you can sort of
hear the different qualities
of where songs were written,
subliminally, I feel like.
JASON ANDREAS: That's great.
Where's the album
title come from,
the inspiration behind that?
SHAKEY GRAVES: Well,
the album title really
comes from hearing the
songs all together.
The nice part about the
narrative of this record
is that I wrote the music
first, and then the lyrics,
and then titled it,
and then sequenced it.
So it's always a wild way
to build narrative out
of something that
you already have
and actually listen to the
music that we had started
to write and ask
yourself, objectively,
like, what does this sound like?
You know, sort of
like writing a score,
writing a verbal
score to music, which
is the inverse of writing
a musical score to a movie
or something.
You know, it's kind
of the opposite.
JASON ANDREAS: Absolutely.
And I read too that when you
sat down with this album,
before it even came
to fruition, you
had this idea that you
wanted to roughly follow
"The Wizard of Oz."
And that was a lot
of the inspiration
behind some of the musical
motivation in this album.
Tell us about that,
because that's wild.
SHAKEY GRAVES: The main
thing with "The Wizard of Oz"
is that it was the best analogy
I had for basically wanting
this record to really embrace
going into color, so to speak.
Because the first albums I
have, even the record covers,
are all in black and white.
And it wasn't like
an intentional thing.
I just liked the monochrome
covers that I chose.
And then eventually
I was like, well, you
know, what do I do
for this record cover?
And I wanted to address
everything as opposed
to just being like, we got
some new sounding stuff.
This is how it is.
And like, ah, you know, it's
a song about, blah blah.
I was trying to make sure
that each thing was sort
of meticulously unpackagedable.
So for this, the
initial concept I
wanted for this was to be
a double-layered record.
And so this would
be like the top.
And there's a little
me right here in there.
And I wanted the top of
it to be all Technicolor
and then my image to
be in black and white
and then it to be
an inverse and it
to be basically the
same street or whatever,
but it would be a
really boring monotonous
road in black and white.
And then my image
would be in color.
And it was like, whoa!
You know, the duality
of fantasy and reality.
And then I was like, how
am I going to make that?
And I didn't.
So.
[LAUGHTER]
But that one thing
led to another,
and it ended up just
kind of sticking
with this version of it.
And you can see that there is
like, this is a model that I
built in my house.
So that's my actual head
to scale, the whole thing.
So it was like a series of--
I used an old Disney
technique of layering cells,
you know, like animation cells.
So this is a layer, and
then that's a layer.
And it's all spread back, and
you take a photo through it.
Some of these are real little
train buildings and stuff.
And I built a road out of clay
and had a ball in my house,
and I was like, yeah!
Look, it looks good!
JASON ANDREAS: Do
you still have it?
Is it still in your house?
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah,
it's slowly kind
of falling apart and melting--
JASON ANDREAS: Melting, yes.
SHAKEY GRAVES:
--melting into itself.
And my girlfriend's
like, can we move it?
I'm like, don't touch it.
Don't touch it ever.
JASON ANDREAS: That could
be the follow-up album.
SHAKEY GRAVES: "Don't Touch It"?
JASON ANDREAS: The melted
version, and it says
"Don't Touch It."
SHAKEY GRAVES: Oh, good call.
Yeah.
That's a great idea.
JASON ANDREAS: Just give me
executive producing credit
if that does come out.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: I
never noticed, too.
I saw an interview
where you were
talking about the album,
which is incredible.
You guys-- you might not be
able to see it from here,
so we can come do a close-up
afterwards, but it's awesome.
I can't believe
that you built this.
It's fantastic.
And then I never
noticed that you were
like peeking in from the top.
You're like I'm on
the album cover twice.
You're down here,
which is clear,
and then you're peeking
in from the side.
So, well done.
SHAKEY GRAVES:
That was also the--
you know, I guess "The Wizard
of Oz" thing stuck in my brain
and was a good reference
point to tell the other band
members too, that
initially I even wanted
the sound of the record to
start thinner and sort of more
colorless and then it
to really get wild.
And instead of it being so--
you know, that's a
great thing to go into,
having a great, stable plan.
But once we hit the beach
and started like, ah!
It was like, what's happening?
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
I read, too, in terms of
like musical inspiration,
not just artistic but musical
inspiration from the album,
there's even a couple
songs that have
a little bit of a Beatles'
"Sergeant Pepper's" feel
to them.
You mentioned Harry Nelson
as a big motivator in this.
I think Wu-Tang
Clan was mentioned.
SHAKEY GRAVES: They're always
mentioned, Wu-Tang Clang.
JASON ANDREAS: Wyatt's rocking
the Wu-Tang hat back there,
which is fantastic.
For you, you talked
about the process
of how you went from step one
to the album release in terms
of though process.
Where do those
musical inspirations
come in throughout that?
Is it during the writing
process, the recording process,
everywhere?
SHAKEY GRAVES: I mean,
I think it's the same.
There's no real direct
influence on the whole record.
There's some songs that as soon
as you started to write it,
you're like, what does
this remind me of?
Then you're like, oh, yeah,
this is just a Kinks song
that we did ourself.
But instead of trying to
directly reference something,
it was more if we started
down a road and things started
to sound a certain way,
it was like a confidence
in following that, as
opposed to like, are we sure
that this sounds
like Shakey Graves?
Because that was a weird
concept to ask myself.
JASON ANDREAS: Absolutely.
SHAKEY GRAVES: And then I was
like, what am I talking about?
What is that?
What does that even mean?
And is that important?
And so, you know,
not that it was
trying to sound like a Nelson
thing or sound like whatever,
but in certain parts it's
like, oh, let's layer vocals
and be more comfortable singing
in a certain voice that maybe
isn't the typical thing but
just to use the same narrative
quality that that
Nelson gets away with
and the Beatles, you
know, for that matter.
JASON ANDREAS: Did that
make you nervous at all,
kind of challenging the
perception-- because you
mentioned it just a
minute ago, like, what
does Shakey Graves sound like?
What's the sound?
What is the theme?
Did challenging that
perception for your fans,
for yourself, was
that ever something
that made you nervous
through the process?
SHAKEY GRAVES: Oh,
yeah, absolutely.
And then at the same time, it's
like I sort of try and make,
you know, commandments for
myself every once in a while.
And they revise constantly.
But it's always nice
to look back at rules,
maybe, that you write.
And they can be
arbitrary but just
like simple, like there is no
Shakey Graves or something.
And you're like, whoa!
And some days it's important
to remember that the reason--
to look at the history of why
I put any of this together,
you know, the suitcase,
why I even go by a name
is that I wanted this
to be a project that
could be malleable.
Like, early Shakey
Graves stuff doesn't
sound like Americana music.
It sounds like 17-year-old
who listened to a few low fi
and noise records and
was like [MIMICS SINGING]
and playing stupid
loops of things.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
It works.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah.
And you guys haven't even
heard any of that stuff,
but you will one day
and be like, oh my god!
JASON ANDREAS: The
unreleased tape.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah.
But for me, it's like
this is a project
that I want to make
sure defies or surpasses
kind of genre specificity,
because that's its point.
And I feel like it started
to go maybe a little
too far into the
simply Americana realm.
And not that that's
a bad thing at all,
but it was important
for me to make
sure that people understand
not that I'll never
make stuff that sounds folky
or whatever ever again.
I'm not like, it's over!
I'm not going to touch
an acoustic guitar
or sing about the
woods ever again.
I'm not going to do it.
It's more like, I have
a ton of other things
that if I didn't express or
get to follow this rabbit hole,
I'm not sure I'll ever see
the other side of creativity
that I so yearn for.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
How's the fan reception
been so far at shows?
I know you've been out playing
for a couple of weeks now.
How's the fan reception
been with the new stuff?
SHAKEY GRAVES: It's been great.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah?
That's great.
SHAKEY GRAVES: The show is
disorienting, which is good.
It's kind of the point.
And I've seen a wonderful
response from that too.
And, you know, I'm
sure some people
are like, what is he doing?
But overall, it's like a
shock and awe kind of thing.
And the subtleties that
we're doing onstage,
I've gotten to talk to people
who've never seen the show
or listened to the music,
and it worked on just
like a man on the street.
And I was like, yes!
We got you.
They're like, yeah, when you
play with that one light,
it's like it's weird.
It's like a campfire,
but it's purple.
Then you do this thing.
And then you turn
on part of the set.
And it's like,
whoa, other stuff.
I'm like, yes, keep talking.
JASON ANDREAS: 'Cause
you're going for it.
SHAKEY GRAVES:
That's exactly right.
JASON ANDREAS: I love it.
I want to talk about
one song on the album.
We talked about this
just a minute ago.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: It's
called "Aibohphobia."
You've got to look it up.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Check it out.
JASON ANDREAS: I'm not
even going to talk anymore.
Tell us about the song.
SHAKEY GRAVES: No, I want
you to describe this song.
JASON ANDREAS: OK, OK.
SHAKEY GRAVES: [LAUGHS]
JASON ANDREAS: This is one
of the songs when I first
heard it, I was like, this has
got such a cool sound to it.
That's when I mentioned
"Sergeant Pepper's" a minute
ago.
It does have kind of this up
and down beat, very Beatles,
"Sergeant Pepper's" type vibe.
So it immediately drew me in.
And then I started
listening to it.
So aibohphobia is actually
a palindrome of itself.
So it's spelled the same
way front as it is back.
We all work at Google.
I can't assume you all know what
a palindrome is, though, so I
helped you out on that one.
But the song, the lyrics,
if you listen to them,
there's so many
palindromes thrown in.
And the entire last sentence
is a palindrome on itself,
which when I looked at
it, I had to actually like
sit there for about 30
seconds to figure it out.
And it's incredible
how you've done it.
So it's not only a really
cool sounding song,
but to me, it's mind-blowing in
terms of the way you wrote it.
And again, I told
you, mind-blowing
for various reasons.
But you talk about
where that came from.
You've got some really
serious songs on the record.
You performed one
for us earlier.
But where does a fun
song like that come in?
What's the process behind that?
SHAKEY GRAVES: I
mean, it's funny, too,
because I don't really
feel like any songs I
make are too serious.
And that's not true.
Some of them genuinely
are, but there is always,
for better or for worse, a
sort of playful sense of,
like, I don't really know
what I'm talking about.
Because that's kind of how
I see a lot of the world
in the first place, is
that I think it's all just
sort of like, I got this.
It's like, yeah, you got this?
Yep, totally got this.
And everyone's
like, (WHISPERING) I
have no idea what I'm doing.
Like, what is this?
Like, nope, got it.
Don't worry about it.
JASON ANDREAS: We do that
every day here at Google too.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Everybody
worldwide is just like, got it.
(WHISPERING) I have no
idea what I'm doing.
You know, it's just--
like falling with style, you
know, in the eternal words
of Buzz Lightyear.
But the "Aibohphobia,"
specifically, is definitely a--
it's a song that made us
laugh when we wrote it.
And it kind of
started as we were
trying to write a more
serious song indoors,
and then outside my buddy
Rayland Baxter and my guitar
player Pat were riffing
on "Oh You Pretty Thing"
by David Bowie.
JASON ANDREAS: Oh
yeah, absolutely, yeah.
SHAKEY GRAVES: I
think that was it.
Or maybe it was
"Suffragette City."
And they were just like
messing with the chords.
And then he started-- the
first line of the song
is, "I met her at
the chocolate shop.
She was shopping for chocolate."
And we were like,
whoo whoo whoo.
That's so funny.
Like, why that's
funny, I don't know.
JASON ANDREAS: It works.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah.
Then we kept like coming out,
and someone would add a lyric.
And then someone
used a palindrome,
and then I was like,
oh, palindromes!
And we looked up this
giant list of palindromes
and then started sucking
them into the song
and then found that giant one.
And we were like, oh, we
can put this to music.
And by the end, we had this
crazy sing-along song where we
were trying to stuff words
into it that we'd like--
our bass player was like,
put "scone" in there.
We're like "scone"?
How are we going to
put "scone" in a song?
We did.
We put it in there.
It's in there.
JASON ANDREAS:
Anything is possible.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Yeah, you
can put scone in stuff.
You know, "kayak," "nurses run."
We tried to get a lot of really
silly palindromes in there.
And Aibohphobia is a term for an
irrational fear of palindromes.
JASON ANDREAS: Oh,
yes, good point.
Yeah.
Everyone here is going to run
out and listen to that song.
Please do.
Because it's good.
It's got a great quality to it.
Let me clarify too, in terms
of the more serious side.
I was referencing just
one song in particular,
and maybe the
background behind it
is not as serious as I thought.
But the "My Neighbor" song.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Oh, sure.
JASON ANDREAS: You kind
of talk about living--
the way that I read
the lyrics is you're
living so close to
folks every day.
You've got neighbors
to the left and right.
And you don't
necessarily know them
or trust them other than
maybe just a casual wave.
And that's what I was
kind of talking about.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Sure.
JASON ANDREAS: In
today's society,
like, I feel like
that's so true.
For some reason,
that spoke to me.
As I said, I live in a
[INAUDIBLE] community
and sometimes feel the same way.
So that was a little
more of a serious topic,
is kind of what I was thinking,
but not in a very serious
depressing way, by any means.
SHAKEY GRAVES: No, I'm with you.
I mean, the one through
line on all of this
is that all the songs are
kind of just little snapshots
of modern living for me.
And I think there's a lot of
irrational fear and fantasy
in the world and
in my own world.
And that's the kind
of stuff that I
think was worth me playing with,
you know, like the one song
about a monotonous routine
and then fantasy that also--
both of those
things seem absurd.
Spending all day dreaming
about walking on the moon
while you're spending all
day just hating yourself,
it's like there's bound to be
something in between that's
both attainable and not
so self-deprecating.
But it's easy to
get sucked into--
you know, for instance, "My
Neighbor" can go two ways.
It can be like stressed out
about everyone around you,
or being like, why
doesn't anyone talk to me
in my neighborhood?
And both of those are valid
and irrational sometimes
at the same time.
JASON ANDREAS: Well, that's
the cool thing about songs.
In most cases, they can be
interpreted in different ways,
even different than the way
you write them in some cases.
SHAKEY GRAVES: I try and
leave them open-ended often
to make sure.
Because I've had
people be like, I
know what this
song's about, man.
It's about being like
an old man in prison.
And I'm like, what?
This one's about
my dog, you know?
Maybe he is an
old man in prison.
You know, whatever.
JASON ANDREAS: I'm always
cautious when I ask questions,
because I don't want to--
the way that I ask questions
is how I interpret things,
but it's clearly
not always right.
SHAKEY GRAVES: No, I would
rather you interpret something
that I make than me try
and force my brain on you.
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome.
Well, thank you.
Very good stuff.
I skipped over some
general questions.
I'm going to go back to it.
Anyone can easily YouTube
previous interviews
that Alejandro has done
about where his name Shakey
Graves comes from.
But I love the way
he tells this story.
So where does Shakey
Graves come from,
for those of us who
haven't seen it yet?
SHAKEY GRAVES: This is
where I go off road,
and I'm like, I don't know.
I read it in a book.
It's basic-- that's
the whole story.
JASON ANDREAS: Oh, shoot.
SHAKEY GRAVES: I tricked you
with that internet video.
JASON ANDREAS: It's over.
SHAKEY GRAVES: No, my friends
and I were at a music festival
in Austin, Texas, which
is called Old Settlers.
And it's like a weekend,
and people play music.
You don't have to
go see the music.
The campsites kind of
have their own life.
And I had been writing
music and hadn't come up
with an alias name that I had
really found appropriate yet.
And I took my guitar
back to Austin
and went to go test my
mettle at these campsites.
And one of these days,
like maybe mid-afternoon,
we're sitting around
drinking beer next to a fire.
And this heavily
tripping man came up
and was like just fried.
And he had a big
24-ounce beer on him.
And he's like, hey, man.
What's the-- wow, wow.
Look at this.
Try my whiskey, man.
My whiskey's so good.
And we had a long, loopy
conversation with him.
And he kind of made us
all try his whiskey, which
we just kind of like
pretended to drink out
of this big hot can.
And he was like,
oh, it's so good.
It's such good whiskey.
We're like, yep.
And by the end, he
sort of teetered off
and was like, you guys
are good people, man.
Keep it up.
You know, watch out
for the spooky wagons.
And the last thing
we heard him say
was like a warning
about spooky wagons.
And we're like, did
you hear him say that?
And it's like, yeah.
And then we kept
talking about it
and realized that it would be a
great name for like a Nashville
guitar picker, sort
of like Speedy West
or something like that.
We're like, Spooky Waggins,
like W-A-G-G-I-N-S.
And so my friend
was Spooky Waggins,
and I was Shakey Graves.
And then his girlfriend
was Spinster Jones.
And then his other
friend was Solomon Doors.
And then his little brother
was asleep at the time,
and so we named
him Droopy Wieners.
[LAUGHTER]
And he woke up and was
stuck with that name.
And that's the most famous
name out of all those names,
because I made one
internet video about it.
And now at least
three to 170 times
a year, someone just
goes, Droopy Weiners!
And like sometimes in public
and other people are like,
what the-- what's happening?
How's Droopy Wieners?
Because I'm always like
hanging around, you know.
JASON ANDREAS: I'll be
at the show tonight.
So if you hear it,
it's definitely me.
SHAKEY GRAVES: OK, good.
JASON ANDREAS: Definitely me.
I was going to ask a question.
Since we are at
Google, we sometimes
tie a very rough
technology question in.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Shoot.
JASON ANDREAS:
Today's day and age,
there's this
pressure, especially
amongst younger kids, to like
maintain this digital presence,
right?
It's all about getting likes
and clicks and things like that.
You, again, based on
my interpretation,
talk a little bit,
in a very kind
of light way on the album--
I think the song's
"Kids These Days"--
you talk a little
bit about that.
But I feel like, even
just from hanging out
with you for the past
two hours or so, you
have a very cool
down-to-earth vibe.
Like, how do you maintain
that type of vibe in a world,
in the music industry, in
the entertainment industry?
You lived in LA for a long time.
You did some acting early on.
Is it all a show?
Are you really a
pretty chill guy?
SHAKEY GRAVES:
Oh, good question.
JASON ANDREAS: [LAUGHS]
SHAKEY GRAVES: No,
I'm a very mean man.
[LAUGHTER]
No, I don't know.
You know, my age is someone
who put me young in a time
where there wasn't
really internet.
Like, I can't remember
having dial-up in the house,
and at a point where when
I was in high school,
it still wasn't
insane if you didn't
have a cell phone at all, let
alone a smartphone, period.
And I didn't get a phone
until maybe my junior year
or senior year in high school.
And then that still,
but I played video games
and stuff as a kid.
And I understood
computers and wasn't--
basically, I grew up kind of
on the cusp of these things,
where I'm not scared
of technology.
It doesn't stress me out.
I feel pretty capable.
And you know, I
use a smartphone,
and sometimes feel like I'm
really good at the internet
and stuff like that.
And then at the same
time, all this technology
is growing in such
an exponential way.
And the way that it's
interfaced with changes
entirely like generation and
just sometimes month-to-month.
And it can be overwhelming for
everybody involved, I think.
But it's, again, a
reality and not something
that is to be ignored
or feared in any way.
You know, it's still part of
even the stuff in this record.
Like a lot of my anxiety
comes out of the internet.
Because like maintaining
a social presence
or putting yourself out
there now has direct response
so quickly someone can
just be like, you suck!
And you're like, ahh!
And you just forget about
the like 40 other people
before that that were
like, changed my life,
having a great time.
One dude's like, your balls!
And you're like, no!
And at the same
time, you know, if I
go see some movie I don't
like, I'm like, your balls!
I'm like super into it.
So it's like a
glass houses thing.
We're all living in glass
houses at this point,
and we're just chock
full of stones.
And I don't know where
it's going to lead.
And my level of participation
with the internet
has to, again,
change day-to-day.
I've noticed I can
just relax so much
more if I don't have my phone.
But then sometimes it's
the most necessary thing,
because I'm also a business
person, because I'm technically
the head of the snake that
leads us all on tour and stuff.
So sometimes I have
to answer questions
in a reasonable amount of
time or I fuck everything up.
So it's like, I don't know.
I'm sort of waiting to
see where this goes.
And I always am looking for
a simpler, more helpful way
to do things.
And then at the same time,
it's always necessary for me
to go back to pen and paper.
So I think that's
kind of the problem
that everybody
keeps going back to
is like, how do you have an
organic, futuristic society?
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
You mentioned earlier
something that
struck me in terms of
some of the feelings
on the album, these extremes.
You don't have to be terribly
bored with your life,
and you don't have
to be an astronaut.
You can be somewhere in between.
And I think the same thing
goes with technology.
There are some good
things about technology.
There are some great
things about it.
But there's also some good
things about vinyl record
albums and pen and paper.
If you can find
somewhere in the middle,
that's, I feel, where
the happy medium lies.
But it's really hard
to find that sometimes,
because people do tend to
go one way or the other.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Well, I
mean, one of those fantasies
of technology--
it's also the scary part--
is the dream that it's so
ingrained and so imperceivable
that it almost just
looks like magic.
JASON ANDREAS: Absolutely.
SHAKEY GRAVES: And that's
where a lot of stuff is headed,
and it's also where that like
"Terminator 2" fear of like,
do I want my body chipped?
Where it's like, (ROBOT
VOICE) Hello, Alejandro.
Welcome, your coffee's ready.
And it's like, that's awesome.
I would love if coffee
was popping out of walls
everywhere I went and my TV
shows were following me around.
But, like, is that
really what I want?
Who am I?
It's like, I don't know.
JASON ANDREAS:
Maybe we can start
with programmable lighting
that talks to our mood,
and we'll go from there.
SHAKEY GRAVES: It's
still the same color,
so everyone must be
happy at this point.
JASON ANDREAS: It's good.
Awesome.
Well, listen, Alejandro,
this was fantastic.
Thank you so much.
Again, I know you've
got a busy schedule.
Thank you for stopping
by, hanging out
in an office on your day
off or your time off.
We really appreciate it.
SHAKEY GRAVES: It's
my real pleasure.
JASON ANDREAS: Awesome.
SHAKEY GRAVES: This is what
it's like in an office.
JASON ANDREAS: Now you know.
SHAKEY GRAVES: This is what
every office in America
is like.
Cool.
JASON ANDREAS: Well,
thank you so much.
Another round of
applause to Alejandro.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I appreciate it.
That was awesome.
SHAKEY GRAVES: Cool.